let's talk about thrift
thrift is a concept where you reduce
reuse and recycle but yet with an
economic aspect
i think has a real potential for change
my grandmother she knew about thrift
this is her string jar
she never bought any string basically
she would collect string it would come
from the butcher's it would come from
presents
she'll put it in the jar and then she
would use it when it was needed when it
was finished but it was tying up the
roses tightening up a part of my bike
once you've finished with that it will
go back into the jar this is a perfect
idea of thrift
you use what you need you don't actually
purchase anything so you save money
kids also inherently know this idea when
you want to throw out a cardboard box
the average kid will say don't
i want to use it for a robot head or
when you use a canoe to paddle down a
river
they understand the value the second
second life of products
so i think thrift is a perfect
counterpoint
to the current agents we live in all of
our current products are replaceable
when we get that bright new shiny toy
it's because basically we've got rid of
the old one
the idea of that is of course it's great
in the moment
but the challenge is as we keep doing
this we're going to cause a problem
the problem is that there is really no
way
when you throw something away it
typically goes into a landfill
now landfill is basically something
which is not going to go away
and it's increasing current at the
moment uh we have about 1.3 billion tons
of material every year going into
landfills 2100 is going to be about 4
billion tons
see instead i prefer if we started
thrifting and what that means is
we consider materials when they go into
products
and also when they get used and at the
end of their life when can they be used
again
the idea of completely changing the way
we think about waste
so that waste is no longer a dirty word
we almost remove the word waste
completely
all we're looking to is resources
resource goes into a product
and then can basically go into another
product
we used to be good at thrifting my
grandmother again
used to use old seed packets to pay for
the bathroom walls
i think though there are companies out
there who understand this value
and are promoting it and a lot of the
technologies that have been developed
for the smart age can also be adapted
to reduce reuse and also thrift more
proficiently
as a material scientist what i've been
tracking over the last couple of decades
is how companies are getting smart at
thrifting
how they're able to understand this
concept and profit from it
i'm gonna give you two examples the
first one a good one the second one not
so good
the first is the automotive industry
okay not always known as the most
innovative or creative of industries
but it turns out they're really really
good at recycling their products
95 percent of every single car that goes
on the road gets recycled here
and of that car about 75 of the entire
car
goes and actually gets used again that
includes of course the
steel and aluminum but then also the
plastics from the fender
and also the interiors glass from the
windows and the windshield and also the
tyres
there's a mature and successful industry
that deals with these old cars
and basically recycles them and puts
them back into use
as new cars or other new products even
as you move towards
battery powered cars there are companies
that claim they can recycle up to 90
percent
of the 11 million tons of batteries that
are going to be with us in 2020
that i think is not perfect but it's
certainly good and it's getting better
another nice reason they're not doing so
well is the architecture industry
one of the challenges with architecture
has always been when we build up we
don't think about taking down
we don't dismantle we don't disassemble
we demolish
that's a challenge because it ends up
about third of all landfill waste in the
u.s
is architecture we need to think again
differently about this
there are programs that can actually
reduce some of this material
a good example is this is actually
bricks that are made from
old demolition waste which includes the
glass includes the rubble includes the
concrete
we put up a grinder put it all together
heat it up and make these bricks we can
basically build
more buildings from but it's only a
fraction of what we need
my hope is that with big data
and geo-tagging we can actually change
that and we can be more thrifty when it
comes to buildings
if there's a building down the block
which is being demolished
are the materials there that the new
building being built here
can use can we use that the ability to
understand
all the materials that are available in
that building are still usable can we
then
basically put them into a new building
without actually losing any
value in the process so now let's think
about
other industries what are other
industries doing to create thrift
well it turns out that there are plenty
of industries that are also thinking
about their own waste and what they can
do with it
one a simple example is the waste that
they basically belch out as part of
industrial processes
most metal smelters give off an awful
lot of carbon dioxide
turns out there's a company called land
detector is actually working in china
and also seeing
south africa that's able to take that
waste gas
about 700 000 tons per smelter
and then turn it into about 400 400 000
tons of ethanol which is equivalent to
basically
powering 250 000 or quarter of a million
cars for a year
that's a very effective use of waste
how about the products more close to
home this is a simple solution
and it again takes the idea of reducing
reusing but then also with economic
advantage
so it's a simple process of changing
from a cut and soap where typically
between 20 and 30 materials are used
which are cut from a large cloth and
then sewn together or even sometimes
glued
they changed and said they just knitted
the shoe the advantage of this is not
just a simplification of the process
it's also i've got one material i have
zero waste
and then also i'm able to potentially
recycle that at the end of its life
digital manufacturing is also allowing
us to do this a little bit more
effectively in this case it's actually
creating the theoretical limit of
strength for a material
you cannot get any stronger for the
amount of material than this
shape so it's a basic simple block
but the idea is i can extrapolate this i
can make it into large formats i can
make it into
buildings bridges but also airplane
wings and shoes
the idea is i'm minimizing the amount of
material
here's a good example from architecture
typically
these sorts of metal nodes are used to
hold up large tent structures in this
case it was in the hague a large
shopping center they used 1600
of the materials on the left the
difference is by using the solution on
the right was they cut down
on the number of steps from seven to one
because the one on the left is
currently welded the one on the right is
simply just printed
and it was able to reduce waste to zero
cost less money
and also because it's made out of steel
can be eventually recycled at the end of
its life
nature also is very effective at thrift
think about it nature has zero waste
everything is useful for another process
so
in this case nano cellulose which is
basically one of the very fine building
blocks of cellulose which is one of the
material that basically makes
one of the things that makes uh trees
strong you can isolate it
and it works very much like carbon fiber
so take that from a tree
form it into fibers and then those
fibers can strengthen things such as
um airplanes buildings cars the
advantage of this though is it's not
just it's bioderived comes from a
renewable resource
but also that it is transparent so it
can be used in consumer electronics
as well as food packaging not bad for
something that basically comes in the
backyard
another one from the biosource is
synthetic spider silk
now it's very hard to actually create
spider silk
naturally you can basically get it from
spiders but in large numbers they tend
to kill each other
and tend to eat each other so basically
you've got a problem with creating in
the same way you do regular silk
so what you can do is you can take the
dna from the spider and put it into
various different things
you can put into bacteria you can put it
into yeast you can put it into milk
and what you can do then is um the milk
or the bacteria
produces much larger volumes and then
from that spin a yarn
and then create a fabric or a rope again
bioderived
has incredible strength about the same
as kevlar so they're using it in things
like bulletproof vests and helmets
and outdoor jackets has that great
performance but again it's bioderived at
the end of its life it potentially can
go back into the soil
get composted to again be potentially
used again as a
new material
i'd like to leave you with one last one
which is bio-based but this i think is
like the ultimate thrift
think about the poster child for
conspicuous consumption it's
the water bottle we have too many of
them they're basically going everywhere
they're they're a problem in the ocean
what do we do with them this process is
able not just to recycle them but to
recycle them infinitely and why is that
interesting because
when we think about reusing and
recycling metals
glass um things like that can be
recycled as many times as you like
there's metal that's basically in your
car that may well have come from a 1950s
oldsmobile
because you can recycle inflate without
no loss of performance plastics after
about
once or twice of recycling whether it's
a bottle whether it's a chair
whatever it is it's a carpet after two
times the recycling whether it goes back
into another chair etc
it tends to lose strength it's no longer
any use this though just using a few
enzymes
is able to recycle it infinitely so i
take a bottle or a chair
or some other plastic product i
basically put it in with a few enzymes
they break it apart
they basically put it back into its
original molecules and then from those
molecules
you can basically build another chair or
carpet or bottle
so the cycle is infinite the advantage
of that of course is that
you have potentially zero loss of
material resources
again the perfect idea of thrift
so in conclusion i just want to have you
think about
the way if you make anything if you're
an any part of a design firm if you
basically are refurbishing your house
any aspect in which you
will you make something think about how
that product could potentially be used
as a second life or third life or fourth
life design in
the ability for it to be taken apart
that to me is the ultimate thrift and i
think that's basically what my mother
would love
you